now we hit the acting section I noticed
some nominees in New York I think they
might have gone home we'd better check
let's switch over to New York and see
what's playing there well thank you Bob
all the nominees and possible winners
are now here we're all ready and willing
we just hope to come up with with a
winner soon and we all want to send our
word to the beautiful ladies out there
to stop worrying about television they
look simply lovely keep Johnny green
happy I'll give it back to you in just a
moment we're swinging around to see a
few of the nominees who have arrived see
Shirley booth back there
Kim hunters arrived winner from last
year Mercedes McCambridge is still here
you look fine Conrad very fine
and I shot a little like Bobby Driscoll
air today wonderful Conrad presenting
supporting actor a certain mrs. Miniver
better known as award-winning actress
Greer Garson
those nominated for the best performance
by an actor in a supporting role are
Richard Burton
my cousin Rachel 20th Century Fox alpha
Honeycutt the Big Sky Winchester RKO
Victor McLaglen
the quiet man Agassiz Republic Jack
Toland sudden fear Kaufman RKO Anthony
Quinn
Viva Zapata 20th Century Fox and the
winner
ah in the absence of the winner mrs.
Anthony Quinn will accept you
I'm sorry that Tony couldn't be here but
when I let him know today is my
telephone I know you'd be a very happy
man
thank you very most calls must be
wonderful